j'attends nos policiers et nos gendarmes
la plus grande des ontologies améliorer
la déontologie des forces de l'ordre
c'est ce qu'avait réclamé manuel
maquereau en janvier dernier au
gouvernement
cinq mois plus tard et six jours après
une première manifestation d'ampleur à
paris christophe castaner rappelle que
la france n'est pas les états unis et
souhaite appliquer une tolérance zéro
contre le racisme dans les forces de
l'anp porter l'uniforme de policiers ou
de gendarmes
c'est un honneur et chacun doit s'en
montrer digne
ces dernières semaines trop ont failli
dans leurs devoirs républicains des
propos racistes ont été proférées les
discriminations révélé c'est
inacceptable
aussi j'ai demandé à ce qu'une
suspension soit systématiquement
envisagée pour chaque soupçons avérés
d'actes ou de propos racistes
la méthode interpellation controversée
dite de les tremblements est également
abandonné ne sera plus enseigner leur
déformation école de police
hasard du calendrier c'est également ce
lundi que l'igpn la police des polices a
rendu son rapport annuel
et les chiffres sont alarmants 1460
enquête leur ont été confiées durant
l'année 2019
un nombre en hausse de 23 7% par rapport
à 2010 8 868 concernent des violences
volontaires soit 41 % de plus que
l'année précédente
des chiffres en augmentation et une
crise de confiance des citoyens à
l'égard des forces de sécurité comme l'a
constaté le défenseur des droits jacques
toubon dans son rapport annuel
depuis qu'on est passé de gardiens de la
paix a forces de l'ordre se trouve
qu'ils s'en ils s'en servent un petit
peu trop là en ce moment malheureusement
il est plutôt négatif quoi va de manière
générale je vois que la police française
elle est là pour faire respecter les
lois
et peut faire régner l'ordre la société
ont fait pas dit que la police française
elle est un système on peut comprendre
qu'ils aient des agents de la police qui
sont racistes face et ça se comprend en
fait il ya des violences policières
depuis quelques années et qu'elle a du
mal à reconnaître et à s'autodiscipliner
dans ses rangs voilà mais c'est pas
forcément de sa faute c'est la faute à
l'état qui donne pas forcément d
instruction ni des formations adéquates
à l'appel du comité adam à une nouvelle
mobilisation nationale est attendu ce
samedi alors que le procureur de la
république de paris confirme que la
justice veut auditionner deux témoins
clé dans le cadre de l' enquête sur la
mort d'adama traoré après son
interpellation le 19 juillet 2016 à
beaumont sur oise